- Don't edit that part out either
because I love that the
VaynerNation's gonna hear
that you messed up and
stopped it too soon.
- [DRock] Oh, I stopped recording.
- What's that, oh you didn't
you have that part either.
Oh, you're really killin' me.
Alright, you ready?
On this episode, I answer
a bunch of questions
but the funny part is, they're here!
You keep asking questions, I'll
keep trying to answer them.
(upbeat hip hop music)
Hey everybody this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching Episode
26 of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Fun fact about the number 26
is it's this man's best favorite number.
Hey everybody, it's me, as you can tell.
Different setting, as you can tell.
I am actually in New York
City on a all day event
speaking with Seth Godin,
Dave Ramsey at an event.
(upbeat hip hop music)
And so I decided to mix
it up and bring people
backstage in the green room with me.
This room's actually green,
which kind of makes it funny,
and have them ask the questions so
let's just get right into it, get in here.
Tell the VaynerNation who you are.
- Garrett Green from Nashville, Tennessee.
I wanted to ask, you talk
a lot about challenging
the main media source in your business.
I know you brought up like, companies
like creating a golf website,
it takes on Golf Digest
and every once in a while
there's a sponsored post,
and I know you've done it with CheeseRank.
For smaller companies, that
don't have all the resources
for editors and content creators and such,
what do you recommend for them or is this,
you think this is kind
of the next evolution
that's gonna become more
of a product people use?
- Thanks for the question,
it's a great question.
Yeah I mean look, this
is what I believe in
and for small businesses, I recommend
doing what I did in 2006, which was look,
there's a difference between
Buzzfeed and Seth Godin's blog
right, there's a lot
more content everyday,
there's a lot more
stuff, but Seth puts out
his best effort once a day.
For me, I did a wine show, I mean,
it's what I'm doing right now, I mean.
In theory, I could staff
up even more than DRock
and Stunwin and put
out Q&A shows all day long,
go the Oprah model and
have people underneath me,
there's a lot of ways to go.
But if you believe in what I believe in
which is every business is
becoming a media company,
all of a sudden, you're taking
hours away from staffing,
strategizing, selling, all
the other things you're doing
and you're putting one, two, three hours
into becoming a media company
and I do believe that has
enormous upside, I mean,
not much has changed for
me since I viewed the world
in 2009 and wrote Crush It!
The only thing that's changed is,
I'm even more confident I was right,
because there's more of that happening.
The things I wrote about in 2009,
that people thought were ridiculous like,
you know, a 15 year old
is gonna have more people
that they think are famous
on YouTube than in real life,
that's now happening.
You know, if anybody has
15 year olds, let him in,
if anybody has 15 year
olds in their lives.
Hey Dan, you need me now?
I'm taping a show, do I have time?
- [Dan] No no, you're fine, I
was coming to ask about this,
if you wanted the guys to be a part.
- Yeah, I mean, oh those guys, the guys?
I will, but let me bang out this show.
You know, you're not editing.
So to me, I would just
say, if you believe in it,
and you don't have the resources,
then respect your belief
and put in your time
and actually do it, versus
all the other things
you could be doing.
- Awesome.
- Thanks brother. Next, let's go.
Tell the VaynerNation who you are.
- Nathan Ruff, thenathanruff.com,
I own a web design and development company
called OneNine--
- Nice plugging, nice plugging.
Tiger, love it, love
the plug, go ahead Nate.
- The question is I feel like
a lot of small businesses fail
because they refuse to--
- Dude, who are you
asking the question of,
VaynerNation or me, let's go.
- Sorry.
- Go ahead.
- I feel like a lot of
small businesses fail
because they refuse to accept
what they're not good at.
For example, I suck at accounting,
so I have somebody do accounting for me.
But I see people, you know,
they suck at photography,
but they're still doing their photography
and it's hurting their brand.
- Yeah.
- They're not accepting that.
- Okay.
- Your thoughts on that.
- Cool, thank you.
I mean, you know, again,
as somebody who's been
following my stuff, I think
we agree on this, right.
Like I'm a big fan of going
all in on your strengths
and outsourcing or not
focusing on your weaknesses.
I think you got it pegged
right, I think the one thing is
sometimes it's obvious right,
don't get caught in the obvious, meaning.
It's obvious to you that
you suck at accounting.
It's kinda easy right, it's math.
You probably also don't
wanna or like doing it.
That's easy.
It's the thing that's in the
shadows, that's not as obvious.
There's something you're doing right now
that a lot of people
could do better than you.
It's easy when you're an F at
it, and you know you need an A
but what about the fact that
you might be doing something
right now, a tiger somewhere else,
where you're a B at it,
but you could afford
to have somebody be an A at it.
That's where people make mistakes so
it takes deep self-awareness, you know.
I'm not a big believer in like,
try, try, try, try harder,
be better at this thing.
I think it's a waste of resources,
energy and happiness often.
Now, if you get off on that kind of thing
like perserving, knock yourself out,
roll how you wanna roll but for me,
big believer in betting
on all your strengths
and trying to find complements
to your weaknesses.
- How would you--
- Oh a new one for #AskGaryVee like
this is cool, when they're
live, they can follow up.
- How would you bring up, you know,
people have terrible
websites, it doesn't even
work on a mobile device and
they're just not getting,
do I just accept that
okay, they're gonna get it
and walk away, or how
would you bring up, saying
hey, you're not really good at that.
- Now you're asking me a
sales question, I think right?
Like are you saying, to reach
out to somebody and say,
"Hey we should do that for you."
- No, even just like from just
a help in providing value.
Like hey you're not good at
this, I don't think my company
is the right fit but
you're not good at this,
I'm just telling you like--
- You know, one of the
things that I do tactically
is just call people out on it, right.
I'll reply to them publicly
on Twitter and say,
"Hey, you just tweeted wrong, here's the."
You know, my classic, like everybody
does this wrong on Twitter.
You know, I'm not scared
to, my route is simple.
Polite, polite, polite,
you're not getting it,
and I still care enough,
which is very rare,
then I'm gonna drill you in your face.
Thanks man, enjoy, next let's go.
I like this, I like this DRock.
- Alright, my name is Nik Parks
and Gary, I'm just curious,
so let's say if um,
you were just born to be an entrepreneur,
that's just what you do and I'm sure you--
- I believe in that.
- Well until you're an
entrepreneur like that,
you're not gonna be fulfilled.
- Yes.
Talking to me about my
first 18 years of my life.
- Yeah, so that's my
question, like at what point
are you being fiscally responsible
and what point is it just
like analysis paralysis
where you think well, I
can't go into full time yet,
I need a full time job.
- That's a tough question.
Now I understand what you're saying so.
Let me make sure I dissect this properly.
For people like me that happened to
feel that they are that and
then happen to be good at it,
it's easy right, 'cause it worked out.
Are you asking me, if you feel
like you're an entrepreneur
but you're not good enough
to be an entrepreneur
that can sustain a lifestyle
where you have to balance
something else, what do you do?
- Maybe--
- Or do you keep trying,
or are you asking,
actually I apologize 'cause
now I'm recalibrating.
How long can I go at it,
thinking I'm an entrepreneur
until I have to wake up
and say wait a minute,
am I tricking myself, and let
me get a little more practical
and jump off that train?
- I mean more like, say
you have a full time job
and it's good pay, good
benefits and all that.
- If you have a full time job,
you're not an entrepreneur.
You have to understand, that
is a very important part here.
You may have entrepreneurial tendencies,
you may have aspiration
to be an entrepreneur
but when you are an entrepreneur,
you can't breathe having
a job, you can't breathe.
Now look, maybe I'm the extreme of it but
the fact is, especially
right now, especially
I'm guessing at some
level, this is for you,
not your friend kinda thing,
or it might be a friend
or it might general.
You're so young that you have
so much less risk than the,
look, when you're 18 to
29 in American today,
by all standards, to
me, that's your time to,
if you're an entrepreneur,
you're being an entrepreneur.
If you're ready and willing to take a job,
then you have entrepreneurial tendencies,
and that's a thing you have to figure out,
but to me there is no such
thing as an under-30 year old
entrepreneur that has a
job, it doesn't exist.
- Alright thanks.
- Alright man, thanks.
Chef get in here.
You notice her from the comments section,
she's always there.
- Hey guys, Chef Lizette.
- Alright calm down, calm down.
Alright promote, promote.
- Hey hey hey hey hey, Chef
Lizette, @ChefLizette1.
- Alright.
- Anyways, so you know,
I wanna piggyback on that
because you were capturing a certain
demographic and age group
so I wanna represent
all those who are a little bit older.
So I'm asking it for them, you know.
- Okay.
- People who already have
kids, financial commitments,
homes, mortgages, blah blah blah,
so when you keep talking about
how do you audit your
time, how do you analyze
what character traits, can
you speak to the older folks,
between the 30, 50-somethings,
how to go out and make it happen
or analyze do you really
have what it takes,
because at this point,
these folks probably have
10+, 15 years of experience
in their endeavors already.
- The one thing I think, thanks Chef.
The one thing that I
think is interesting is,
let's break down the question
a little bit differently
which is, there's a
level of never being able
to fully make it but
still being in a process
where you enjoy the effort to get there.
This is not an all sum
game, I'm okay with somebody
being a nuanced entrepreneur,
where there's a full time job
and they're trying to make it happen.
Because what happens is,
you're almost talking about
being an entrepreneur as a hobby there.
Right, it almost takes
on, this is something,
and I just got goosebumps, so I'm starting
to get into a new thing that I'm trying to
figure out how to
articulate, I'm doing it here
out loud for the first time which is,
when does entrepreneurship or going for it
take on, morph on, whether
it's very practical,
'cause you're asking for the
for the 35-55 year old demo,
or when it's, you're still
under 30, in your 20s,
but you've confided into
or picked a job route,
when is it actually in hobby land?
- Exactly.
- When is it, you like
having your side hustle
and you're enjoying it,
but it doesn't need to
or have to become your
life and you don't have to
make a billi, for you to be happy.
So, what I would say is,
if you're up at night
and you can't breathe and
you have to do your thing
well then, you just
might not be good enough.
I mean, think about all
the people we've seen
on American Idol who are
like, "I grew up my whole life
"and I knew I was gonna
be Whitney Houston."
You're all pumped and you're
like, back when people watched
and you're like, you can do it!
And then she like, "Aaah!"
and you're like no,
and it's delusional, but we
have that in entrepreneur land.
I get emails every day,
I meet people every day
who are delusional about their skill set.
I desperately, desperately, desperately
want to be the small forward
of the New York Knicks.
If I truly acted on that,
like if right now at 38,
I'm overseas trying to be
the 13th man on the bench
of an Italian B-league
team, that's not gonna work.
It's not gonna happen no matter what I do,
and so, I think the answer
to your question for me,
to make it as valuable
for them as possible is
are you willing to get
comfortable in accepting
that you're in hobby
zone versus transitioning
into that zone, and if you
are, well then in a weird way,
that's your question, these tie in.
You can have a best of both worlds.
- Right.
- If you're asking me
like, how to get somebody
to become self-aware
enough and not delusional
that they're hurting
themselves, that's not something
I know how to really fully answer.
- Cool.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
- Do you want to jump in on the show?
I know you came in late.
- Great how are you?
- Wanna take a selfie real quick?
- Yes, I was actually gonna ask you.
- Hold on everyone, don't edit, DRock.
Alright, you got it?
- How's my fro?
- You look amazing.
- Thank you.
- Oh you did it, you really
know what you're doing.
Love it, um, tell everybody,
tell VaynerNation who you are.
- Hi VaynerNation, I'm Allie DeCastro,
@Ms_Allie_D on Twitter.
So my question is, I'm actually
really glad I'm asking it
one-on-one and not in
front of the audience,
and now that it's being filmed.
The audience is way
huger so, way more huge.
So I have a job that I absolutely love,
I actually work for ReMax of New Jersey.
You spoke for us pretty much
right before I got hired
so I just missed you.
I love my job. I love what I do.
I do social media and graphic design.
I work with SEO company.
We develop content
and of course I want to get
into doing my own thing,
doing my own blog, starting my own hustle,
and I have this, and I know it
stems from a fear of failure,
but I have this really hard time.
I get like crippled when
it comes to like executing,
and I know you're probably
just gonna be like
just do it, (beep) them,
go for it, do your thing--
- You know me so well.
- I just need to hear it like, I need you
you to look me in my face
and tell me what I should do.
- Do you want it?
- Yes, I do.
- And so literally you're
just scared to fail?
- Er.
- I mean, if you want to go
deep with me, I'll go deep.
Who are you scared to fail in front of?
Is it your mom? Is it your
best friend? Is it your sister?
That's the only thing
that holds people back.
Something happened to me,
like everybody thinks like
oh I'm so nice, look at
what I'm doing right now.
Truth is, I don't give a shit
about anybody else's opinion
so rawly that I'm never scared because
if I fail and people
are like, "See hahaha."
It doesn't even register.
In the same way, when people are like,
"You changed my life, you're the best,"
I'm able to be grounded,
because it also doesn't.
You know, I'm kind of in
that middle zone, right,
like not too high, not too
low, which would confuse people
based on my energy but I
equally care about every comment
in the YouTube section of this
episode, I'm gonna read 'em
but if somebody says, "You
blow and this format stinks,"
and, "You should let DRock
edit," that's gonna be okay.
And so, if you wanna get deep with me,
I know for a fact, 'cause
you've already given it to me
that it's the fear of failure,
now the question becomes to whom.
And what I would do is, and
you don't have to share that
with the whole world, I'd go
talk to that person up front.
The best practical advice I've
ever given in this scenario,
and it works over and over is you go
and you sit down with
dad and say, or Johnny,
or your boyfriend, or your
sister, or your girlfriend,
I don't care who it is right.
You sit down, you look
'em in the face and say,
"I'm about to do this and the only reason
"I haven't done it for the last year
"is I don't want to let you down,
"because entrepreneurship is a crapshoot,
"and I'm not sure if I'm gonna win,
"but long term I'm gonna win,
"and I just need to make
sure if I fail on this step,
"that your response to me doesn't crush me
"to never let me have a second at bat."
'Cause that's what it is.
- Okay.
- Right?
- Yes.
- That's it.
- Alright cool, thanks Gary.
- You got it.
Alright everybody, thank
you so much for watching
this little improv, show
them, this looks really cool.
Thanks for watching Episode 26.
Question of the day.
You know what, you really
inspired me with that question.
I don't know if the camera
caught the little tearing,
but that was fun for me and I was like.
You know what, I'm glad,
I thank you so much
because that's a piece of
advice I've never shared
with my audience. I've shared it privately
but that's why this show
is like what I want.
You guys are massively helping me
because a lot of you, I'm over here.
(laughing)
You guys are helping me massive,
I just want you guys to know this too
because you're getting new stuff out of me
because you're making me more creative
by asking these things.
So I'm gonna ask that.
Who's that person in your life right now
that you so desperately
don't want to let down,
that you admire and love
so much that it may be
holding you back from somebody,
or something, excuse me.
I want you to leave that in the comments
because I have a funny feeling
if you leave that comment,
it may start the process
to a very, very good thing.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe!
(makes video game sounds)
I need the subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social.